time it's the second day in a row it
looks as if death valley
actually broke its record of hottest
official temperatures for the day can
you believe it
kirsten joyce joins us now with more
details on that
ted we did break another record in death
valley for the day it was set back in
2001 of 124 we reached 127.
keep in mind these results still need to
be verified by an expert panel of
specialists
but the national weather service says
yesterday death valley recorded a high
temperature of 130
and when verified it will mark the
hottest temperature recorded on earth in
over 100 years
the temperatures are measured at the
visitor center in furnace creek using an
automated observation system
now the hottest temperature ever
recorded on earth was in death valley
july 10 of 1913 and it measured 134.
dan burke with the national weather
service says he doesn't think it's
likely we'll hit 134
this season but he says every time the
temperatures at death valley get close
to 127
128 while the phone starts ringing he's
been on the phone non-stop since this
morning talking with european agencies
japanese agencies it's certainly getting
a lot of attention
for august we're already on pace to be
the hottest august ever although we
still have
another 14 days he also adds this
extended heat wave is really an anomaly
because he says in mid-august we no
longer have the most sun that we
normally have and to see these kinds of
temperatures this late in the season is
extremely rare
now death valley is the sum in the
summer is really popular with european
tourists we chatted with the front desk
at the oasis of death valley
and the gal tells me she's received a
ton of calls today from journalists she
says their occupancy is less than 30
percent right now with some
international
gas and she says those who checked in
had no idea about the heat wave we were
in for this week
and apparently found it quite amusing
brian